bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouvel
épisode de probablement qui va être un
petit peu spéciale puisque en fait j'ai
sauté sur l'occasion après une visite
des laboratoires de ibm à zurich
d'interviewer des chercheurs à ibm
zurich et du coup j'en ai profité
notamment parce que le domaine du
hardware en informatique est quelque
chose que je connais finalement
relativement peu du coup ce n'est
absolument pas une promotion un
placement de produit pour ibm
là c'est vraiment moi qui les ai
contactés parce que j'étais vraiment
curieux d'en savoir plus sur la
recherche qui avait lieu à ibm
zurich est donc ce que vous allez
écouter ça va être trois interviews que
j'ai fait deux trois chercheurs à ibm
zurich
donc le 1er lucas va être beaucoup plus
sur des problématiques de cpu en
particulier et puis plus grand de tous
qui est à revoir un peu classique ce
qu'on utilise aujourd'hui mais jusqu'où
ça peut aller et comment est-ce qu'on
projette le futur de ces technologies
l'a ensuite on va avoir une interview de
manuels qui va nous parler de hardware
neuromorphic qui est vraiment des trucs
un peu révolutionnaire qui est en train
d'être mise en place pour pouvoir faire
du du calcul spécialisé fin des machines
à calculer spécialisé pour les réseaux
de neurones et du coup pour
l'intelligence artificielle moderne et
enfin de la partie on va parler avec
daniel de l'ordinateur quantique qui en
est vraiment à ses tout premiers
balbutiements et pensant on n'est pas du
tout autour de solutions tout à fait
commercialisable mais la recherche
avancée avance à grands pas et sans
doute entendu parler par exemple de
suprématie quantique
donc ça avance et on verra quels sont
les défis à relever mais également
comment est-ce qu'on n'imagine utiliser
ce genre de rer dans le futur donc la
qualité audio est pas top tout du long
en particulier avec daniel vous allez
voir c'est pas tip top du tout donc je
m'en excuse mais je pense que les deux
premières interviews sans hébergement
etc ou tables et puis bon pour la
troisième fois vous êtes très motivé
offrir un effort soit ben désolé et
bienvenue pour ce nouvel épisode de
probablement du coup j'ai accueille
aujourd'hui
lucas jeu pour ensuite nous
de keke chercheurs à ibm zurich
notamment sur microprocesseurs
bonjour les cas ce que tu peux commencer
par te présenter un petit peu quand on
perd quoi donc comme tu l'as dit je suis
lucazeau massa fait une dizaine d'années
que je travaille chez ibm research à
zurich
je travaille principalement sur les
matériaux semi conducteurs
le microprocesseur comme tu l'as dit et
également pour les technologies qui
tourne autour des micro processeurs pour
micro processeurs entre eux comment
faire pour les rendre intégré dans le
système radio et voilà et on s'est
rencontré il ya pas longtemps lors d'une
visite de notre titre et je suis très
contente de pouvoir continuer la
discussion avec toi silva est ce que tu
feras commencé par expliquer ce qu'est
un microprocesseur pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas du tout donc un
microprocesseur c'est un peu comme un
ordinateur en fait un ordinateur ces
composés principalement de deux éléments
le le cerveau donc le micro processeur
et la mémoire escaut fait un ordinateur
c'est quand on lui quand on lui demande
de réaliser des actions
il prend des données dans la mémoire qui
sont envoyées aux microprocesseurs
le microprocesseur traite les
informations sur des calculs retourne un
résultat et le résultat ensuite est
stocké dans la mémoire c'est la base du
fonctionnement d'un ordinateur et donc
la mémoire elle sert juste à stocker
l'information donc on va dire un peu
plus
et lui me sers c'est lui qui traitent
l'information donc c'est lui qui est un
peu le qui rend le système fonctionnel
un peu lui qui est au coeur de la magie
derrière un ordinateur
est ce que tu vas nous parler un peu de
l'histoire du microprocesseur tout ça
vit ça commence il ya 70 ans environ en
1947 l'invention du transistor on va y
revenir après je crois mais le
transistor c'est la brique de base qui
sert à construire un microprocesseur
donc ça a été un 21 1947 à bell labs et
ensuite ça a pris une dizaine d'années
jusqu'en 1958 pour que on arrive à
construire les premiers circuits
intégrés c'est à dire qu'il est intègre
plusieurs transistors entre eux pour
réaliser une fonction et ensuite c'est
allé très vite deux ans après ibm a été
la première entreprise à faire une
production de masse de circuits intégrés
donc je dis circuits intégrés c'est un
peu on va dire l'ancêtre du
microprocesseur universcience simplifié
à simplifier de ce qu'est un
microprocesseur aujourd'hui mais ça a
commencé comme ça et ensuite tous ces
cinq ans après il ya ce qui s'appelle la
loi de moore qui a été établi par gordon
moore on peut aussi à part les détails
un peu plus tard trois ans plus tard
gordon moore à fond de intel avec
d'autres copains d'heure qui aujourd'hui
est très connu comme étant un des
fournisseurs principal de
microprocesseurs pour le grand public et
puis en 1974 il ya une autre loi que je
pense que j'aimerais on discute
aujourd'hui qui s'appelle la loi de
bénard qu'à être mis en place par un
chercheur chez ibm et à structurer toute
l'industrie des semi conducteurs pour
expliquer comment voir rendre les micro
processeurs toujours plus performants et
ensuite fin des années 70 début des
années 80 donc les microprocesseurs
devenu de plus en plus complexes etc et
était basé sur une technologie de
transistor qui s'appelle les transistors
bipolaires années 70 début des années 80
on a basculé sur la technologie et qui
s'appelle la technologie ses mains ce
qui est la technologie qui existe
toujours aujourd'hui et depuis une
augmentation constante du nombre de
transistors de la performance une
diminution de la consommation d'énergie
arrivé au point où un ordinateur qui
quelques dizaines d'années prendre un
immeuble entier aujourd'hui tient dans
la poche du smartphone et nous permet
d'être non seulement de connecter que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui un peu moi
c'est l'une des créations les plus
impressionnantes que l'on a pu faire en
termes de à quelle vitesse
est ce qu'on a réussi à changer le monde
et à quel point est ce que on a maîtrisé
la matière et créer des systèmes aussi
complexe le processeur ça contient
milliards de transistors
on est allé 1 70-1 du premier transistor
à plusieurs milliards dans votre poche
c'est assez impressionnant du coup j'ai
pas expliquer ce qu'est un transistor et
pourquoi est ce que c'est si important
donc un processeur ou un ordinateur ça
marche avec ce qu'on appelle des beats
donc un beat c'est une unité
d'information on va dire et c soit 0
soit 1,1 et comment est ce qu'on
représente ça est-ce qu on traite ça
dans un microprocesseur donc on a besoin
d'un interrupteur ouvert soit fermée et
qui du coup a représenté 1 0 un seul
ainsi les ouvert ou fermé on peut voir
ça comme un interrupteur mécanique pour
allumer ou éteindre la lumière
sauf que on fait pas ça de manière
mécanique dans une dans un micro
processeurs en fait ça de manière
électronique et le transistor cc c'est
exactement ça c'est la version
électronique de l'interrupteur 1 va dire
une entrée et une sortie et ensuite ça
un troisième signal qu'on appelle la
grille qui sert de contrôler si
l'interrupteur est allumée ou vraiment
la brique de base
ok mais quand on connecte un don qu'il
ya toute une théorie qui explique
comment est ce que on peut connecter
entre eux des transistors pour créer des
circuits logiques et les circuits
logiques sont à la base on va dire c'est
le plus petit sous systèmes et quand on
compte entre combine plein de circuits
logiques entre eux on arrive à créer des
fonctions et à la fin on crée un
microprocesseur qui va contenir à
l'époque au tout début
quelques dizaines de transistors et
aujourd'hui quelques milliards de
transistors et c'est qu'on a intérêt
d'avoir plus de transistors
il faut le voir un peu comme on va dire
chaque fonction qu'on veut faire
réaliser par un microprocesseur demande
un certain circuit logique derrière et
chaque circuit logique d'un certain
nombre de transistors
donc si on veut pouvoir faire un trait
tout un ordinateur dans un smartphone
d'accord ça veut dire qu'il faut pouvoir
faire entrer toutes ces fonctions là une
puce qui est tout petit et donc il va
falloir mettre transistors nécessaires à
réaliser ses fonctions il va falloir les
faire rentrer dans cette puce qui est
tout petit vu les fonctionnalités qu'on
a aujourd'hui on voit l'utilisation
qu'on en fait quand on communique par
l'a5 j'ai un regard des vidéos en haute
définition
on a des des algorithmes d'intelligence
artificielle qui tourne dans le
téléphone fait de la photographie du
traitement d'image etc
toutes ces fonctions elle demande un
microprocesseur très très performant et
pour pouvoir réaliser ça on a besoin
d'eux de l'ordre du milliard de
transistors pour le faire à l'époque les
premiers transistors et il était de
l'ordre du centimètre premiers qui ont
été créés ou du millimètre plus tôt
aujourd'hui on est dans le nanomètre
c'est cette réduction de taille des
transistors qui a permis d'en mettre
suffisamment sur une puce aujourd'hui
pour rendre les microprocesseurs aussi
performants ils nous permettent de faire
autant de choses d'ordinateurs ou de
téléphones et de clichés du jeu convient
sur les milliards de transistors du coup
il ya plusieurs cirques logique qu'ils
sont conçus avec ça et du coup c'est
comme si elle plusieurs fonctions
préprogrammées sur le microprocesseur
c'est oui et non c'est c'est vrai dans
l'image de ce que j'ai décrit pour
expliquer simplement mais en réalité on
essaye de faire en sorte que circuit
qu'on réalise il soit pas dédié à bas
donc on peut en revenir pour le pour
l'avenir bus jusqu'à aujourd'hui on
essaie de faire en sorte que les
processeurs il soit le plus générique
possible c'est à dire que processeur il
va fournir un fait une liste
d'instructions d'accord qui sont en fait
la base de ce qu'utilisent les gens qui
programment des logiciels pour
programmer leurs logiciels
c'est la première couche que fournit un
ordinateur il fournit le jeu
d'instructions du processeur on essaye
de faire en sorte que ces instructions
soient suffisamment générique pour
pouvoir représenter le plus de cas
possibles selon ce qu'on veut faire
ensuite au dessus de ça les gens au g
des drivers peut-être dû parler de
driver et pardessus d'aider les
applications système d'exploitation etc
et qui au final question ce qu'elles
font c'est qu'elle utilise les
instructions un générique du processeur
des tâches qui mises les unes après les
autres
fin mai minuit vitesse du processeur de
cegedim processeurs des comtés en giga
hertz est lié au nombre de transistors
ou pas vraiment là en fait le quelque
part oui disons plus un transistor est
petit plus il va vite plus il va vite
plus on peut augmenter la fréquence de
fonctionnement donc les gigahertz plus
la fréquence de fonctionnement est élevé
plus le processeur va traiter les
informations rapidement et donc plus la
machine va être dans l'idéal est en
pratique vu que veut mettre de plus en
plus de trente histoires dans une
surface petit ça vaut ça revient entre
les transistors de plus en plus petit et
donc
conséquence ça revient à rendre aussi
les transistors beaucoup plus performant
ok c'est qu'il n'ya turisas sion et le
face qui permet les deux campus voilà le
coeur le coeur c'est la miniaturisation
la miniaturisation permet on peut parler
ces deux-là de la loi de moore et de la
loi des normes la miniaturisation permet
de réduire les réduire la consommation
d'énergie d'augmenter la performance et
de augmenter le nombre de fonctions
qu'on peut faire réaliser un autre un
micro ok quand on gagne sur tous les
tableaux
du coup tu peux parler un peu de la loi
de moore qu'est ce que c'est la loi de
mars est la plus connue dans cette
industrie est en fait c'est s'est rendu
compte après quelques années à étudier
l'industrie des circuits intégrés à
l'époque que en fait le coût d'un
transistor était moyenne divisées par
deux chaque deux ans donc c'est une
observation qui l'a fait à l'époque est
donc ce qu'on appelle la loi de moore
c'est que il a postulé que c'était
quelque chose qui était assez
fondamental à l'industrie et à les
continuer pendant longtemps c'était un
peu une prévision du modèle économique
de cette industrie qui dit voilà et on
arrive à réduire le coût d'un transistor
par deux tous les deux ans ça veut dire
qu'on va pouvoir en mettre beaucoup plus
et donc on va faire les choses plus
performante et donc on va gagner des
parts de marché et on va rendre cette
industrie de plus en plus importante
l'aspect économique des années plus tard
il ya donc ceux des neufs de dehiba
chercheurs et bm qui a créé là l'aspect
technologique
derrière cette loi et qui expliquent est
ce qu'il faut faire pour diminuer la
taille d'un transistor et pourquoi
science et la dcri que si on suit sa loi
c'est c'est lui qui a expliqué que la
façon de réduire le coût par deux
c'était en réduisant la taille du
transistor d'une certaine façon
en suivant cette loi on pouvait à la
fois que j'ai dis juste avant on pouvait
gagner donc on pouvait accélérer le
transistor on pouvait réduire la
consommation d'énergie et aussi réduire
le coût donc c
qui à gordon moore il a donné la vision
on va dire et des nerfs il a expliqué
comment il fallait faire
ok les gars et donc depuis pendant des
dizaines d'années l'industrie a suivi
ces lois en disant bon bah il faut que
je divise de toutes les dimensions et
géométrique de mon transistor les deux
ans pour pouvoir tester hockey et
pourquoi du coup c'est pourquoi est ce
que vous arrivez à 10 et par des jeux
couper les transistors attend en deux
tous les deux ans on veut être
on les coupe pas en deux parce que si on
les coupe en deux ils marchent plus gêné
on essaie à ce qu'on doit faire c'est
essayer de couper en deux les dimensions
c'est à dire à toutes les eaux final
voilà comme je l'expliqué il ya une
entrée et une sortie et il faut que
toutes ses dimensions là soit réduite
d'une génération à l'autre ce qui a été
un des moteurs principal principaux de
cette réduction c'est ce qui s'appelle
la lithographie
si tu as entendu parler de lithographie
c'est technique c'est un peu comme de la
photographie mais à l'échelle
micrométrique à l'époque et nanométrique
aujourd'hui c'est à dire au final ce
qu'on a un morceau de matériaux c'est du
silicium sur lequel on fabriquait micro
et on veut venir dessiner sur ce
matériau la forme des transistors qu'on
veut fabriquer et donc c'est ça que le
procédé des lithographies c'est celui
qui vient de dessiner sur le matériau
les plans du circuit intégré il a fallu
améliorée au cours de toutes ces
dizaines d'années de réduction d'état il
a fallu améliorer les procédés de
lithographier pour pouvoir dessiner les
transistors de plus en plus petit et du
coup les fabriquer de plus en plus
petits pendant très longtemps c'est ça
qui a été le une délimitation principal
sur lesquels beaucoup de développement a
été fait pour pouvoir
diminuer la taille train d'imaginer
qu'une grosse partie du coup c'est
l'amélioration de la lithographie plus
de précisions lithographies permet
d'avoir des micros ses processeurs plus
petits wade après forcément il faut que
les procédés de fabrication suivre c'est
à dire que maintenant quand on a les
plans qui ont été faits plus petit ça
veut dire qu'il faut que tu puisses
structurée de manière plus optimiste que
tu fan des matériaux étaient déposés
dans des endroits plus petit et que tu
puisses il est structuré de manière plus
petit donc tout doit suivre
mais ce qui était le comment dire le
problème principal à résoudre c'était la
lithographie ces dernières années un peu
changé on va dire que depuis un peu plus
d'une dizaine d'années un moment où il
ya peut-être rien dû entendre parler
peut-être de gens qui disent est ce que
la loi de moore va s'arrêter jusque je
répondrais c'est que pour l'instant on
le voit pas la loi de moore continue ce
qui à ce qui s'est arrêtée c'est la loi
de denner la loi de dollars ce qu'elle
disait c'est simplement il suffit de
réduire les dimensions du transistor
pour améliorer tout en fait la loi de
dinars elle s'est heurtée à certains
phénomènes physiques n'existait pas à
l'époque où les transistors faisait de
l'ordre du micron de l'ordre de la
centaine de nanomètres
maintenant qu'ils sont de l'ordre de
quelques nanomètres et quelques dizaines
de mètres on est en train de se heurter
à des phénomènes de de physique qui se
passe dans cette toute petite dimension
donc certains sont liés à la mécanique
quantique que ben on ne peut pas
simplement réduire toutes les dimensions
du transistor et espérer que la
performance s'améliore mais c'est ça qui
a été un changement assez importants ces
dernières années où c'est pas seulement
la lithographie qui était le problème
mais bien d'autres choses pour
comprendre pourquoi est ce que quand je
le fais plus petits transistors au final
il n'est pas plus performant c'était
beaucoup de problèmes de matériaux à
résoudre et ça va vraiment ouvert le
champ des possibilités donc d'un produit
de recherche une période très excitante
problème fondamental parce que on peut
pas dire en 2010 second ben désolé
internet s'écouler l'iphone ça fait
trois ans qu'il est sorti mais on va
s'arrêter là pas dire ça il ya une
industrie multi millionnaire industrie
derrière donc il faut trouver des
solutions il ya beaucoup d'argent dans
cette industrie pour trouver des
solutions donc pour être un chercheur
dans son antre excellent wayne est ce
que j'imaginais avant c'était un peu
business as usual
[Musique]
c'est peut-être si certains de tes
auditeurs sont était dans le domaine et
il ya 20 30 ans peut-être qu'ils ne
verront pas comme ça et c'est peut-être
ma vision naïve
en tant que jeune dans ce domaine je
suis sûr qu'à chaque époque il ya eu des
problèmes très difficiles à résoudre
mais ma vision des choses vu
d'aujourd'hui c'est que adressé pour
réussir à faire améliorer les
performances sont beaucoup plus larges
et du coup créer beaucoup plus
d'opportunités tant que chercheur pour
trouver des solutions parce que tu
utilisais que les transistors de
bordeaux du coup ils font quelques
nanomètres quelques dizaines de
nanomètres
c'est ce à quoi sont à combien d'atonie
compte et nous on pourrait presque les
comptes et donc le donc aujourd'hui ce
qui est en production ça s'appelle le
noeud 7 nanomètres et donc si certaines
ses auditeurs connaissent un peu ou
suivre les microprocesseurs
voilà quand on achète un processeur on
peut voir souvent qu'elle ne de gravure
et l'a été chez et donc les indices et
22 nanomètres
ce dernier qui est en production sur ces
7 nanomètres non mais c'est pas la
taille du transistor et au cours des
années ça a représenté différentes
dimensions du transistor jour
d'aujourd'hui ça ya pas vraiment de
dimension dans le transitoire qui fait
exactement cette non m c'est plus pour
donner un ordre d'idée un transistor m
on va dire certaines des dimensions
critique du transistor sont proches de
ça
[Musique]
le l'épaisseur du canal donc le canal
c'est c'est l'endroit où le courant
électrique et on ouvre on ferme le canal
en fait c'est ça qui fait l'interrupteur
le canal aujourd'hui il est de l'ordre
de quelques nanomètres d'épaisseur donc
peut-être on va dire cinq amis
nanomètres d'épaisseur
ça correspond à je dirais quelques
dizaines de couches atomique les
contenus à briques et que on utilise des
appareils par exemple de microscope
électronique en transmission pour
regarder si la fabrication a bien marché
d'un rose ou musou mais voilà on voit le
transistor avec est utilisée que la loi
de moore n'atteindra peut-être pas sa
fin du coup fait comment continuer le
progrès je disais ça d'un point de vue
dimension d'un transistor d'un facteur 2
tous les deux ans ça c'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui mais augmenter là et la loi
de moore purement à la base c'était
réduire le coût d'un facteur 2 le coup
parte en histoire d'un facteur de tous
les deux ans c'est un peu ralenti c'est
à dire que dernièrement ça devient
tellement difficiles pendant ce que les
investissements qui doivent être faits
en r&d et en production pour réussir à
améliorer les performances font que au
final même si on arrive toujours à
augmenter la densité en fonction de la
loi de moore le coup parte sans histoire
lui il réduit pas aussi vite que ça
c'était donc ça ralentit mais ça
s'arrête pas pour autant
au final
ça transforme c'est à dire que pendant
pendant très longtemps c'était vraiment
critique d'améliorer la performance du
coeur du microprocesseur parce que ce
n'était pas suffisant pour toutes les
tâches qu'on fait aujourd'hui
maintenant aujourd'hui voilà je sais pas
comment qu'on a des auditeurs le voit
mais pour moi personnellement j'ai un
ordinateur
je me rappelle encore il ya il va dire
il ya 15 20 ans si j'en achetais un
autre trois ans après je voyais vraiment
la différence sur les paie aujourd'hui
si j'en achète un et la batterie va
moins bien marché peut-être que j'aurai
un meilleur écran plus tard mais au
final la performance de l'ordinateur
elle améliore pas vraiment qu'au final
on a atteint un niveau de performance
qui est suffisant pour ce que ce qu'on
veut faire au jour le jour
plus tôt ce qu'on fait continuer à
améliorer on va dire l'écosystème
développer des accélérateurs pour
certaines tâches qui deviennent très
critique dans le ministre vie de tous
les jours donc c'est ça qui devient un
peu le grand changement pour moi c'est
voilà les microprocesseurs ce comment la
discuter tout à l'heure c'était quelque
chose
il était conçu pour être générique donc
ça donne des instructions et ensuite les
gens font développe des applications par
dessus pour pouvoir faire un peu
n'importe quelle tâche et au final on
voit aujourd'hui que la façon
d'améliorer vraiment les performances de
l'informatique en général
donc je parle souvent du téléphone ou de
l'ordinateur mais c'est aussi vrai pour
les data center pour le cloud et c'est
d'identifier quels sont les types de
calcul fait très souvent et qui sont
essentiels à notre notre vie de tous les
jours et développer des accélérateurs
qui sont spécifiques pour ces tâches
donc ça revient à créer des va dire des
processeurs très spécialisés par exemple
scélérate heures pour la compression
vidéo on peut faire des accès heures
pour aujourd'hui ce qui est très
important c'est le la préservation des
données donc
privée des gens et faire en sorte que
les données soient cryptée correctement
en crypté des données ça demande
beaucoup de calculs on peut penser que
développe des accélérateurs pour
accélérer l'inscription si
l'intelligence artificielle en général
c'est quelque chose aujourd'hui qui
devient de plus en plus présents dans
toutes les types d'applications et de
services auxquelles on a accès et au
final c'est des types de calculs qui
sont plus ou moins toujours un peu les
mêmes donc faire des accélérateurs pour
ça donc en fait voilà est en fait
l'industrie se transforme al je pense
que l'expérience utilisateur continuera
à s'améliorer dans le temps parce que
arrive à améliorer la performance
globale du système
elle était terminé seulement par le
microprocesseur mais elle est plus
déterminé par les ensembles hockey et
une tête pas du travail sur une
application particulière du cnc puis
spécialisé en particulier
personnellement c'est la plupart des dix
années que j'ai passées ici je travaille
vraiment sur le transistor en lui-même
d'accord le transistor en lui-même c'est
comme on l'a dit c'est la brique de base
du circuit intégré et donc ensuite les
circuits intégrés tu peux l'utiliser
soit pour faire un microprocesseur qui
est générique pour faire un circuit
intégré spécialisé pour faire une tâche
j'ai fait ça aide les deux on va dire ok
dernièrement et finalement ça fait
quelques années que j'ai que j'ai
travaillé un petit peu là dessus mais
notre laboratoire 1 à zurich ça fait
plus longtemps que des équipes
travaillent dessus s'est développé des
accélérateurs spécifique pour
l'intelligence artificielle chose
aujourd'hui on voit partout que ce soit
pour les utilisateurs comme nous ou pour
les entreprises que donner congénères et
qu'on collecte de manière exponentielle
et au final on n'arrive plus à les
traiter en tant que simple humain donc
on a besoin des algorithmes
d'intelligence artificielle très puis
donc ils peuvent les traiter à notre
place pour nous aider à prendre les
meilleures décisions et donc comme je
les dis avant c'est un calcul qui est
très gourmand en performance et du coup
il ya besoin de développer des
accélérateurs pour ça et c'est quelque
chose sur sur lesquels on travaille
beaucoup ici des laboratoires développer
ce genre d'accélérateur ok donc là tu
parle de trucs comme des parce que
aujourd'hui ça passe beaucoup par des
cartes graphiques ou des gpu ou des tpe
passer des trucs un peu comme ça aussi
développer il faut ce qu'il faut voir
voir le système informatique maintenant
un taux commun on va dire le processeur
c'est le chef d'orchestre et au milieu
et qui distribue le travail on va dire
et au final
au final je pense que c'est lui qui en
fera peut-être de moins en moins
c'est-à-dire lui donner les ordres faire
en sorte que les autres travaillent mais
lui-même il va en faire de moins en
moins on va avoir de plus en plus
d'accélérateur au tour du chef
d'orchestre les accélérateurs c'est un
peu comme dans un orchestre les
différents
le spécialiste du violon le spécialiste
de la trompette et c'est un de ces
accélérateurs qui est très utilisé le
jeep y eut donc quand ils disent et des
cartes graphiques
pourquoi parce que ben les cartes
graphiques à la base c'était
principalement développée pour les gens
qui faisaient des jeux vidéo les jeux
vidéo c'est des images 3d et pour
calculer des images en 3d s'il faut
faire des multiplications du matrix et
donc les les cartes graphiques
elle était vraiment développé pour faire
des calculs de matrice de manière
beaucoup plus efficace qu'un processeur
et il se trouve que maintenant avec
l'avènement de l'intelligence
artificielle dans toutes les
applications et services qu'on a ça
devient la nouvelle utilisation des
cartes graphiques parce que dj pee ou
parce que il se trouve que un calcul de
vos neurones qui est utilisé pour
l'intelligence artificielle ça revient
au final à faire des multiplications de
matrix
ça c'est un peu ce qui a changé
l'univers des jeans ou dernièrement
c'est que ben c'est devenu grand malheur
des gens qui font du jeu vidéo parce que
du coup ça fait augmenter le prix des
cartes graphiques énormément mieux la
brique de base qu'on met dans le cloud
et dans tous les data center pour
accélérer l'intelligence artificielle à
dire le premier accélérateur qui a
vraiment explosé en termes d'utilisation
on peut penser à l'avenir que c'est pas
c'est pas la solution idéale c'est à
dire on a gagné beaucoup en basculant
segers artificiel depuis le
microprocesseur donc depuis le cipi aux
audi pignoux mais voilà c'est fait donc
on a eu un certain gain est maintenant
si on veut avoir plus ça c'est une
performance il faut passer sur des
circuits encore moins sur les types ue
ces pays où c'est un un accélérateur qui
a été développé par google qui cloud
il me semble que tissent c'est pourtant
sur flottant sur flo c'est une librairie
que google utilise pour les calculs
d'intelligence artificielle et donc
c'est un circuit qui est du tout
[Musique]
générique il est extrêmement spécialisé
pour accélérer plus d'intelligence
artificielle qui sont faits avec ses
librairies mais c'est entre quand tu vas
faire ça tu vas gagner de performance
que angie pillon je pense que là où en
temps c'est essayer de faire des
circuits qui sont spécialisés pour
accéler de l'intelligence artificielle
ils sont génériques ok c'est ce qui aura
après le thé pew et donc non peut-être
qu est ce qu il faut se dire c'est ben
au final il faudrait faire des circuits
qui fonctionne un peu comme notre
cerveau qu'on appelle ça des circuits
neuromorphic neurones et pas de
transistors et donc la question à ses
bains ci ont créé ce nouveau type de
circuit où la brique de base c'est le
neurone n'est pas le transistor est ce
que c'est qu'un neurone
comment est-ce qu'on crée un neurone
typhi ciel on va dire dans un circuit
intel c'est tout un tout une bande de
recherche actuellement qui est qui est
très intéressant parce que c'est ouvert
c'est-à-dire inventé le nouveau
transistor en quelque sorte qui peut
être une nouvelle brique de base de
nouveaux types de processeurs qui va
être qui va consommer très peu d'énergie
et qui va être très performant pour
faire un tous types de tâches
intelligente moisi c'est des gens qui
travaillent sur les matériaux etc
c'est très intéressant sur la physique
parce que ça veut dire qu'il faut
trouver des nouveaux matériaux qui ont
les bonnes propriétés physiques pour que
mes dans un circuit ça permette de
réagir un peu comme le ferait un neurone
aussi avec les gens les biologistes qui
étudie le fonctionnement du cerveau
parce que plus on va comprendre le fond
si ça peut nous inspirer pour savoir
comment est-ce qu'on peut viser en
quelque sorte un cerveau artificiel dans
un intégré c11 d une des voies pour le
futur donc ce type de d'accélérateur pas
vu une main mais aussi par rapport aux
matériaux est ce qu'il ya des problèmes
de matériaux rares de notre île
environnemental de ce qui s'est passé
question c'est possible parce que
aujourd'hui dans un microprocesseur il
ya peut-être tiers des éléments de la
table périodique qui sont utilisées donc
le contexte géopolitique à un instant t
et le demande c'est possible qu'il y ait
un certain qu'ils soient plus rares ou
plus cher ou souvent des terres rares
des matériaux qui sont beaucoup utilisés
dans l'industrie de l'électronique et
qu'ils sont
il me semble que la plupart des terreur
sont assez bien distribué dans le monde
en termes de ressources donc vous
pourrez les exploiter sauf que sa coupe
c'est très fin a coûté assez cher à
exploiter et donc du coup il ya que
certains pays qui se sont vraiment
spécialisé dans l'industrialisation de
ça et du coup ça
certaines fois discussion un peu
compliqué sur les dépendances du marché
à certains pays et certaines guerre
géopolitique commercial final on s'en
sort toujours avec une question aussi
sur aujourd'hui les des micro
processeurs sont souvent multi coeurs
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
est-ce que ça a continué à gagner en
choeur on a fait des processeurs
multicoeurs parce qu'on est arrivé quand
je l'avais dit avant quand on fait les
transistors plus peut-il dernièrement on
gagne pas forcément un performances en
termes de vitesse nombre de fréquences
de les gigues art qu'on lui dit fait une
quinzaine d'années que les processeurs
et tourne entre 2 et 4 giga hertz et on
reste là et donc pour améliorer la
performance au niveau du système ce
qu'on a commencé à faire c'est au lieu
d'avoir un coeur qu'on peut aller de
plus en plus vite il a commencé à mettre
plusieurs coeurs dans la même puce qui
travaillent en parallèle c'est un peu
comme c'est un peu con me dire avant une
personne qui était très très pour faire
le travail et maintenant on a créé une
équipe
jean qui très qualifiés aussi et du coup
quand ils travaillent en équipes ils
sont plus efficaces que la personne qui
était tout seul avant d'aider
multicoeurs c'est une tendance qui
continue d'autant plus que maintenant il
ya beaucoup de sérieux énormément de
services qu'on utilise qui sont en train
de migrer dans le cloud
leclerc dauphine il faut voir ça comme
on va dire des coeurs disponibles à la
demande
nadir le type de service et le nombre de
requêtes qui arrive à un certain moment
et dans le cloud il va automatiquement
provisionner un certain nombre de coeurs
pour faire le calcul donc faut voir
c'est un peu comme une espèce d'énorme
systèmes multicoeurs dynamique qui
alloue des selon la demande aussi
entendu dire qu'un des gros plans que
c'était le fait que les microprocesseurs
chauffe énormément refroidir dire prisme
c'est vrai et c'est ça aussi qui a fait
qu'on a arrêté d'augmenter la fréquence
parce que dissipation d'énergie dans le
microprocesseur
elle est directement liée à la fréquence
non plus on augmente la fréquence plus
la dissipation d'énergie et grands
moments ben il faut pouvoir
or j ça devienne de la chaleur il faut
pouvoir extraire la chaleur du
microprocesseur sinon entièrement les
performances de transitoire se dégrade à
haute température et deuxièmement à
force ça devient tellement chaud que ça
pourrait fondre j'y allais tellement
élevé que si on les refroidit sais pas
je pense que quand on allume art et un
processeur il fonde avait instantanément
donc il ya besoin de le refroidir
sauf que au final tu peux améliorer le
refroidissement le plus que tu peux mais
un moment donné tu es limité par la
conductivité thermique des matériaux et
les résistance thermique aux interfaces
et arrive à une limite tu peut pas
extraire plus de chaleur par unité de
surface comme une certaine valeur et du
coup tu peux pas
un processeur de dissiper plus d'énergie
que ça c'est pour ça qu'on a arrêté
aussi d'augmenter la fréquence parce
qu'on pouvait plus le refroidir
suffisamment
donc au lieu d'augmenter parce qu'on me
l'a dit avant on a fait une multi coeurs
et à un truc que j'ai entendu je peux je
pense que ça vaut mais c'est comme
aujourd'hui c'est souvent des circuits
imprimés du coup c'est ici tout plat et
peut-être que si on faisait un truc et
on perd en diffusant une teaser un peu
plus la 3ème dimension que vous pouvez
avoir des tripes les puissants c'est un
peu tu peux voir ça comme dans
l'histoire de du chef d'orchestre et des
accélérateurs tu peux tu peux dire c'est
comment est-ce que tu les positionne
donc tu pourrais prétendre situe à 1
j'ai peint à center pour le cloud qui
s'est placé importante mais chacun de
plus de place que dans un téléphone donc
tu peux te permettre d'avoir le
processeur comme circuits intégrés
connecter sur une une board et à côté tu
as un autre tu as d'autres circuits
intégrés qui sont les autres
accélérateur et tu peux imaginer que si
tu veux rendre le système plus efficace
donc un terme de l'espace de coûts de
consommation d'énergie et de performance
à côté donc il faut que tu sortes
l'ex faut que tu sortes du ketch du
premier circuit intégré que tu sois que
tu as sur le board pour entrer dans le
pack agit d accélérateur et ensuite les
outils d accélérateur tout ça c'est de
la perte d'énergie et performance tu
peux te dire je vais les empiler les uns
sur les autres à l'intérieur d'un même
package pour connecter par exemple la
mémoire très très proche du processeur
connecter un accélérateur neuromorphic
très proche du processeur et du rosé
faire des choses qui prennent beaucoup
moins une place donc tu peux les mettre
dans un téléphone qui consomment
beaucoup moins d'énergie parce que comme
la se connecter les circuits intégrés
entre eux et très courte du coup tu ça
consomme moins d'énergie pour faire
passer l'information de l'un à l'autre
donc c'est ça c'est une voix claire
d'amélioration
j'ai une autre question si sur le coût
énergétique qu'est ce qui est le sont
les plus grands coûts énergétiques dans
temps d'un ordinateur aujourd'hui ou
d'un téléphone
et qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pleurer
dur pour un téléphone c'est l'écran que
la moitié vient de l'écran et une bonne
partie vient aussi de la scène géo 4g
des puces qui font la communication si
tu regardes un datacenter
c'est peut-être tiers les
microprocesseurs un tir les
accélérateurs et un tiers le stockage
d'informations au final que ce soit pour
un téléphone ou pour un datacenter la
consommation d'énergie c'est extrêmement
important parce que pour un téléphone
c'est la durée de vie sur la batterie
parce que tout le monde aimerait que la
batterie dure plus longtemps et d'un
datacenter cc directement le coût du
service parce que le la facture
d'électricité à la chaîne du moins c'est
une partie importante du coût du service
le cloud donc c'est des choses qui sont
toujours très critique et qui doivent
être optimisées donc tout ce qu'on a
discuté avant les accélérateurs
l'intégration 3d etc sont des choses qui
améliorent l'efficacité énergétique et
qui du coup ont amélioré les
performances à la dure les coûts ce qui
est d'autres défis de la recherche en ce
moment ne pas encore me suis dit je
pense que si on parle purement du micro
ses soeurs je pense que la lithographie
aujourd'hui revenue au goût du jour
arrivé un moment où les techniques de
lithographie qu'on avait un peu mis de
côté pendant quelques années parce que
c'était suffisant c'est plus devenu
suffisant donc en ce moment il ya une
grosse part de l'industrie et de la
recherche qui est sûr ce qui s'appelle
la lithographie avec des uv extrême
c'est quelque chose qui s'est presque
des rayons x quoi qu'on utilise pour
pour maintenant faire la lithographie et
donc c'est un changement très
fondamental dans la façon dont on fait
la lithographie
il permet pour donner un ordre de
grandeur on passe d'une longueur d'onde
193 km pour dessiner les plans sur le le
silicium a une longueur d'onde à 13 m de
suite c'est comme si on passait d'un
marqueur pour dessiner un pinceau très
très faim quoi ça ouvre des nouvelles
possibilités mais c'est aussi très très
très difficile à faire c'est des
machines qui sont impressionnantes et je
pense ça rassemble dit que du vide des
plasmas des lasers de énormément de
choses des matériaux c'est des choses
très très intéressant d'un point de vue
recherche et après si on parle d'un
point de vue un peu plus chez lecture un
système donc on a parlé des
accélérateurs d'intelligence
artificielle c'est un domaine très très
intéressant et un autre qu'on n'a pas
évoqué mais qui va avec dans leur
castres c'est le cantique puisque c'est
c'est quelque chose sur lesquels on
travaille énormément à ibm
je crois que ça fait une semaine quelque
chose c'est notre nature quantique avec
53,8
il met fin et ça c'est un autre type
d'accélérateur qui qui permet de des
problèmes qui était impossible jusqu'à
aujourd'hui nos ordinateurs vienne
impossible sa révolution dans
l'informatique est un grand challenge de
recherche sur deux points de vue le
premier c'est bien l'ordinateur lui-même
on est un peu comme
retour dans les années 50 60 quand on
était au début du transistor et de leurs
du microprocesseur donc c'est une
période très excitante qui peut définir
une nouvelle nouvelle ère industrielle
de l'ordinateur quantique c'est est ce
que l'ordinateur quantique va s'intégrer
dans leur castres et comment est ce que
on va organiser le calcul entre les
différents types d'accélérateur ça c'est
aussi quelque chose il est complètement
ouvert puisque c'est quelque chose de
nouveau donc ouvert à toute bonne idée
qu'elle est sévère
bah va très bien je reste avec les chose
d'autre à rajouter je pense que je pense
qu'on a on a bien couvert le sujet
j'espère que ça a été intéressant pour
toi et tes auditeurs je trouve ça génial
merci beaucoup beaucoup journée bonne
journée
baboo faire pour gagner pour ce nouvel
épisode aujourd'hui
j'accueille manuel est ce que tu peux te
présenter
oui donc je suis
lui c'est le staff member donc voilà
partie du staff de abi research zurich
et je travaille essentiellement sur une
yole mot fuck you tu es donc ce
essentiellement les bus et d'utiliser un
s'inspirer en fait de la réduction du
cerveau humain de créer des processeurs
de calcul qui peuvent réaliser de façon
efficace en énergie des certaines tâches
de machines est ce que tu vas parler un
peu plus et on parcourt nouveaux
concours ce que tu as à signaler
marco assez compliqué dans coeur ouais
j'ai commencé dufermont bahceli je suis
canadien d'origine donc j'ai commencé
j'ai fait mon match et de la
polytechnique à montréal pendant trois
ans après je suis allé à polytechnique
paris alix pour pour deux ans donc c'est
un
dans un échange de double diplôme à fait
ok j'y vais tous les cursus de
polytechnique paris après monde
les trois ans de battu leur amour donc
voila et après polytechnique je suis
allé à zurich en fait à l'été h pour
pour le grade de master et après voilà
j'ai fait le malaise de master à ibm
ici ça fait là depuis environ parce que
moi cinq ans même plus je crois que je
suis là maintenant donc voilà j'ai fait
mon doctorat aussi à williams mais
maintenant je suis moi j'ai fait
l'envers ça j'ai fait d'avoir pris
technique ap paris france allait appeler
technique à montréal ce que français le
programme qui l'attend est donc doté
d'un talent qui travaillent sur l'
architecture neuromorphic donc que comme
qui a explosé mais c'est de faire comme
comme le cerveau fonctionnement du
cerveau lui même ce qu'il faut être bien
classé qu'on n'essaie pas de reproduire
ces revues mais quand elle entend qu'à
regret donc c'est pas du tout ça l'idée
en fait c'est vraiment de s'inspirer des
différentes façons en fait de la manière
à laquelle cerveau humain traite les
formations et introduire ce type de
concept dans une architecture
d'ordinateurs et que vous passez quoi
les avantages par rapport à simuler ça
parce que si aujourd'hui ces réseaux de
neurones artificiels sont similaires
ouais donc voilà exactement donc
aujourd'hui les des réseaux de neurones
artificiels sont essentiellement simulé
sur des cartes graphiques en fait c'est
vraiment ce qu'on utilise en ce moment
le plus il y a beaucoup de déchets qui
sont de plus qui sont maintenant
fabriqués ou six pour des options
offrent des puces qui vont fonctionner
vraiment en utilisant une puissance qui
est très très faible de l'onu
milliwatts même moins que ça et qui sont
dédiés à vraiment certaines tâches
spécifiques en fait mais dans l'est mais
bon si la plateforme la plus générale en
fait qu'on utilise en ce moment pour
simuler un numéro de carte graphique que
donc voilà la carte graphique en fait
c'est la même chose bon si c'est assez
similaire ça fonctionne de façon
similaire un processeur core c'est à
dire que c'est ce qu'on appelle le
président 8h dans la carte graphique
elle va pouvoir faire n'importe quel
fichier là est ce qu'on appelle un
générateur plus processus assurément
vraiment quelque chose
un accélérateur mais qui voilà qui
essentiellement sillonné de façon
optimale pour traiter beaucoup
d'informations en parallèle ses
espérances avec les processeurs actuels
dans nos ordinateurs et de la carte
graphique
le très grand nombre de coeurs en fait
qu'il est capable de passer ces normes
d'information
en parallèle et voilà c'est pas c'est
pas de cette façon là nécessairement que
le cerveau humain fonctionne le cerveau
humain votre traiter l'information à
travers de réseaux de neurones les
synapses en fait qu'ils sont vraiment
des composants et biologiques
c'est pas du tout comme avoir un très
grand nombre de coeurs des milliers de
cartes qui vont traiter les formations
en parallèle en utilisant une mémoire
externe comme ça qu'on essaie
d'améliorer sur les castes énergétique
en fait étant donné nos cerveaux e-mails
a pas de séparation entre le calcul
mémoire donc avant toute l'information
est traitée à l'intérieur de réseaux de
neurones qui sont connectés par les
synapses
il n'y a pas de séparation entre de
calculer les reniements
tout est vraiment connecté c'est un peu
ce qu'on essaie de faire en fait quand
on parle de cette wii no more fréquents
c'est vraiment ne pas avoir des
processeurs qui accède à une mémoire
externe constamment et c'est ça en fait
qui consomment le plus d'énergie dans
c'est pas nécessairement la cavité de
calcul mais c'est vraiment laid de
l'accès à la mémoire c'est le seul qui
consomme pratiquement sans même une fois
plus d'énergie qu'ils sont passés de
répéter toutes dimensions de 30 mais on
en compte aujourd'hui c'est vraiment le
rappel architecture de one man savoir
des 8es de calcul d'un côté et la
mémoire qui est stockée d'un autre côté
et enfin sont pas très éloignés mais
sont quand même un peu s'éloigner et
aujourd'hui donc à chaque fois qu'on
veut faire quelque chose on est obligé
de récupérer les informations de la
mémoire
jusqu aux unités de calcul faire le
calcul que re stocker 100 en droit et en
fait c'est ce transfert qui est vraiment
très coûteux énergétiquement et c'est
donc après voilà voilà la preuve la plus
simple pour essayer de d'améliorer
l'efficacité énergétique c'est vraiment
de rendre la de rapprocher le plus
possible des unités de calcul et mémoire
donc c'est ça qui fait essentiellement
la carte gars ou même les accélérateurs
utilisent vraiment la mémoire est très
très proche du professeur donc
donc voila mais par exemple dans un
ordinateur traditionnel c'est un peu
près 100 à 1000 fois plus d'énergie
comprend simplement transférer les
données de la mémoire
donc là potentiellement si les nombreux
les architectures neuromorphic arriva
enfin ce vraiment utiliser et fonctionne
vraiment bien on pourrait être divisé le
coût du calcul quantique pour les ja
base des réseaux neurones par 100 ou par
1600 en fait si on compare le processeur
d'ordinateur traditionnel oui mais c'est
encore pas un accident qui est optimisé
avec juste ce qu'ils appellent ainsi que
dans celui appliqué chine spécifique est
vraiment fait pour
kallel hésiter mémoire des calculs très
proche
là je dirais que c'est peut-être de
l'ordre de 10 ou quelque chose comme ça
en termes d'énergie mais ce soit pas
vraiment puisqu'il sera par contre son
corps par un professionnel
et du coup on en est aujourd'hui est-ce
que ça ça fonctionne parce que bon après
voilà il ya pas nécessairement de
produits je dirais encore sur le marché
on peut vraiment quel film noir frigant
fait donc il y à des processeurs qui
sont en ce moment dans les derniers
téléphones en fait par exemple ils sont
des processeurs qui j'appelle des points
les plus spécialisés pour pour accélérer
des tâches d'intelligence artificielle
dans le pays où les choses comme ça mais
où ça reste des processeurs traditionnel
c'est simplement que en fait ils ont
optimisé les fonctions de ce processeur
le et le software également pour pauvres
gens superficiels de façon plus efficace
mais voilà par contre les circuits
neuromorphic ou au pouvoir est vraiment
dire que en émule en fait d'une certaine
façon les fonctions des neurones les
synapses s'est pas encore au stade de
produits finis de google encore au stade
de la recherche énergétique de
l'approché était quand même démontré par
ou de travaux donc cei actuellement
doute là dessus mais par intégrer ce
type de concept en fait d'un terreau
d'un accélérateur qu'on pourrait attaché
un ordinateur traditionnel de la même
façon convenue avec une carte graphique
est d'être capable de wallada de
l'exploiter au maximum et à voir
l'efficacité énergétique qui résultent
de ça en fait voilà d'avoir tous les
softs qui va être capable de programmer
ce type là est d'être capable de
l'utiliser de façon optimale on est
encore moins les débuts de la recherche
ce n'est donc pas un instant qu est ce
qu est ce qu'on arrive à faire nos
recherches dans ce domaine
donc ce soir là la plupart des
démonstrations qui sont faites un baiia
de différentes fréquences est donc tirée
et non une approche en fait la preuve la
plus simple celle approche qui a été
suivi par exemple chrono qui le chip
d'ayem qui est quand même beaucoup de
publicité en fait qui est qui qui
implémentent est en fait un réseau de
réseaux de neurones qui naissent et
comment traduit en français mais c'est
essentiellement qui me voir un seul type
entièrement digitale donc voilà il y
avait différents encore en fait de
neurones les synapses ans que je crois
que c'est 2 956 par 2 5 956 on voit la
connecter un autre en fait donc avec ce
type la préfecture qui utilisent pas de
nouvelles technologies mais en fait qui
utilise toujours la même technologie de
transistors mais qui est arrangé d'une
certaine façon qui me manque un peu
le fonctionnement du cerveau c'est plus
ce genre d'approché lampes qui a été
vraiment démontré pour le moment donc le
type de dentelle dorée qui s'est un peu
de la même façon que je connais pas
exactement mais bon voilà le principe
est le même ce qu'on vaut revoir
on a une architecture qui est
entièrement digitale avec des
ordinateurs traditionnels dans des
transistors et même connexes aussi de
certaines façons mais ça va produire un
peu ce qu'il se passe à l'intérieur du
cerveau donc dans quoi est-ce assez
les puces ont été construites après je
crois pas qu'ils existent encore d'accès
complet qu'on peut vraiment attaché gré
complètement au niveau du système en
fait sinon il ya d'autres il ya d'autres
approches comme celle qu'on n'utilisait
pas comme quand on est parents qu'on
travaille ici à ibm qui sont voilà six
mois je dirais qu'ils sont plus au
niveau de la recherche qu'ils utilisent
pas des technologies transistors des
nouvelles technologies en fait comme par
exemple lorsqu'on utilise et la mémoire
à changement de phase qui est le même
matériau qu'on utilise dans les dvd pour
voilà émuler les fonctions de synapses
des neurones et potentiellement avoir
une meilleure densité consommation de
puissance plus faible qu'on utilise en
transit ce temps donc ce titre cela qui
est vraiment il suivi par certaines
compagnies mais aussi beaucoup à
l'université ça c'est vraiment surtout
en corse et au niveau de la recherche
complet on a des versions plus ou moins
c'est ul de faire une seule tâche qui
peut être réalisé avec ce genre de
système mais voir un support encore au
niveau d'un conduit c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui est encore au niveau
de la recherche qu'on voit c'est de
construire puis général en fait qu'il ai
vécu j'ai une seule tâche spécifique
mais qui peut vraiment c'est un grand
spectacle à la duke ou danser danser
architecture l'information elle est
stockée dans le poids des synapses
[Musique]
mais voilà il ya différentes façons de
stocker l'information à l'intérieur ne
signe absolu puisque ce que je voulais
dire en fait donc les arcs et à ceux
comme de nuit où tout ne les utilise la
mémoire sram donc la seule à même les
voir qu'il se dit dans les
les cages de processeurs voilà après
nous connaissait en fait c'est
d'utiliser une mémoire analogie qui est
cette mémoire à changement de phase en
fait pour stocker l'information à
l'interdît et être capable aussi de
traiter cette information là sans avoir
à utiliser la mémoire du pape une fosse
commune mémoire dinars ou simplement un
peu plus de tension en fait et on va
être capable comme ça de rallier en fait
l'information à l'intérieur ils ont mené
voir comme ça donc
amos beaucoup plus proche en plus de la
façon avec laquelle ne savent où ils ne
fonctionnent que simplement de stocker
des poids des 6-9 son état de fait et
angie tu respires deux buts qu'on
fonctionne la mémoire à changement de
phase c'est une mémoire qu'ils sont en
fait ses mémoires programmables donc
donc un mareyeur changement de phase et
ça comme je disais si les mêmes
matériaux qui sont utilisés dans les
vidéos ni prouvés horaires formation
donc ces matériaux à changement de phase
iib peu changé entre cristalline une
phase 1 mof en appliquant différent plus
de tension donc et la faz am offre une
résistance élevée et la phase qui sait
une résistance humaine
le programme et la phase du matériau
simplement en appliquant des plus de
courant qui essaient etc voilà selon
plus de répéter plusieurs fois ok on
peut faire non nous discutions 9,6 que
la vente la mémoire elle ne fonctionne
plus en fait donc c'est vraiment si vous
deviez levé par exemple que de la
mémoire flash qu'on peut faire environ
1850 discussions cycle avant que la
mémoire
et voilà après on est capable de
c'est comme ça en fait qu'on est capable
d'encoder on fait du poids synaptique
acteurs de ce type de mémoire en
changeant la force du matériau différent
plus de cours
mais est ce que c'est un continuum entre
phases cristallines face au mo s et sa
vie n'est en fait que plus intéressant
pour pouvoir construire des circuits
neuronaux fait que c'est vraiment qu'on
est capable d'encoder poissy natif de
façon à la logique en utilisant une
seule mémoire donc la mémoire c'est pas
seulement dispositif pinard qui va d'un
côté seulement 1 0 1 mais on va pouvoir
accorder tous les états et est remonté à
faire donc voilà je dirais avec ce qu'on
a actuellement chaque mémoire une
pression effectif d'environ 4 b donc ce
qui est quand même relativement
suffisant fait bout d'os lespwa
synaptique note carole généralement une
grande piscine par exemple les actuels
comme l'insinuent celles qui sont les
plus avancées comme vous les nouvelles
cartes graphiques nous parle de nvidia
utilise bibi mancka des fois est ce que
le taux d'erreur lorsqu'on essaie de
d'ajuster le la conductivité et grands
est ce qu'un grand taux d'erreur parce
que seul c'est clair qu'il ya énormément
de défis à relever pour voilà être
capable de ne programmer le poids
synaptique de façon précise donc oui si
on veut faire par exemple ce qu'on
appelle online mining donc ça veut dire
que ce sera un processeur quand vous
pourrez constamment adapter les poissons
tactique en fonction des données qui
reçoit donc là on a besoin on ne peut
pas se faire avec nous à changement de
phase comme ça en fait parce que la
précision d'adaptation du procès
nautiques soit on est amené à utiliser
de combinaison en fait avec avec des
composants digitaux qui uvrent être
capable de calculer de façon le nouveau
poids synaptique est d'être capable de
les coureurs de programmer
change une arche et énergique est super
combiné en fait non c'est un peu la
façon pour le voir il va vraiment avoir
des composants digitaux qui fonctionne
avec une précision élevée qu'ils vont
être capables de faire les tâches par
exemple d'apple son pote synaptique de
façon précise et d'après de transférer
cette information les rouge et noir
changement face qui uvrent capable de
représenter en fait les pois synaptique
de façon relativement imprécise pour des
tâches voilà donc pour ce genre pauvres
pour simplement le propager les données
en fait à l'intérieur ils ont énormément
de précision en fait sur les mémoires
changé la face de cette façon là et même
avec tout le bruit tout l'imprécision
qui assure les personnalités que ça va
fonctionner mais pour adapter les pois
synaptique de façon continue c'est notre
précision des bonnes peut-être plus pour
claquer du coût zéro en garde
utiliseriez deux choses qu'on peut faire
la première c'est du coup car des
prédictions donne des douanes des choses
appelé à passer à la phase d'inférence
et puis une autre phase qui
l'apprentissage qui est amélioré leur
zone et qui sait par contre ce que tu
sais que c'est un peu plus difficile
avec les archers pour l'apprentissage
c'est vraiment une tâche qui en fait il
ya certaines parties de la phase
d'apprentissage qui les inquiète
vraiment beaucoup de précision en fait
même même jusqu'à 32 bits en temps voilà
c'est ça on peut pas faire tout l'étagé
l'apprentissage à l'intérieur de ces
dispositifs d'action en france sont
vraiment
par construction impéritie en fait parce
que c'était des dispositifs en alger
chronos il descend comme la mémoire la
logique et pas de manière juste et donc
des fois ça va et donc tu me donnes je
pense même que à l'avenir ça restera
compliqué de faire ça en fait c'est ce
qu'il faut voir ce que bon de la façon
qu'on voit c'est vraiment qu'il faut il
n'y a pas vraiment ce qu'il faut faire
en fait c'est vraiment d'avoir une
combine l'analogique avec digital donc
il ya certains groupes de recherche qui
est cette femme déjà qu'ils ne soient
complètement la logique mais voilà
personnellement et montséret plus de vie
du couple aussi c'est que ça ne sera pas
de énormément des tâches avec son fait
et ce sera pas tellement ce qu'est le
banc donc ça veut dire coeur que voilà
on peut faire une puce en firent manager
qui bat cas de faire une seule tâche par
exemple voilà entraînés percepts ont à
connaître des numéros de 0,9 mais voilà
faut faire quelque chose de vraiment
général qui va être capable de résoudre
des problèmes plus complexes les deux
façons programmables aussi parce qu'on
veut pas avoir seulement une seule tâche
mais spectre assez large
on n'a pas vraiment fait d'avoir aussi
un processeur digital qui m'ont un peu
capable de faire tout ce que les
mémoires chargement faut donc oublier
ces randos de combiner des trucs qui
sont plus riches avec moscou avec des
rares il est logique qu'ils sont
utilisés seulement pour pour certaines
tâches qui qui ont été démontré qu'ils
peuvent être faites en fait sur les
dispositifs analogique et donc voilà
c'est plus un peu la poche pour en
construire
et donc et sur la phase d'inférence de
prédiction tu penses que ça pourra
rentrer dans le marché bientôt quand tu
vois que mais après bon c'est la tique
on travaille aussi des compagnies de
l'université d'envoi à la face
différence parce que justement elle qui
a pas nécessairement énormément de
précision
bon il ya des pistes qui ont été
réalisés qui l'ont démontré on peut
faire de référence avec ce type de
dispositif à la logique mais voilà après
avoir avoir une puce qui est configuré
pour implémenter différents réseaux de
neurones ses loques
en fait le fils pause parce que voilà il
faut aux rives ou essentiellement avoir
un certain nombre de coeur en fête qui
ont chacun un certain nombre de mémoires
à changement de phase il faut être
capable de communiquer ses différents
choeurs de façon optimale et pourrait
être carrément des différents projets de
réseaux neuronaux comme des réseaux
récurrent en fait donc non cela en fait
que ça devient beaucoup plus compliqué
on est capable de faire une puce qui va
être capable d'alimenter un réseau
spécifique est d'être capable de
fonctionner comme il faut mais voir
quelque chose de l'acide général qui va
être capable de démonter différents
types de topologie en fait c'est là
qu'est ce donc cela d'après ce que je
sais en fait ça vraiment encore été
démontrée mais si là dessus si on est
capable de vraiment montrer une
architecture qui basent sur ce type de
mur à chaque phase et qui garde le
supporter est vraiment un grand nombre
de deux réseaux de neurones
là je pense que éventuellement être
quelque chose qu'ils veulent et qui
pourrait marcher quelles sont appelés
les grands défis de la recherche en ce
moment ouais donc s'ils sont un peu plus
que ce que je disais en fait c'est
qu'elle sait vraiment en fait c'est une
intégration système parce que c'est
vraiment être capable d'avoir un
accélérateur neuromorphic qui peut être
qu'ils programmable en fait
et pour être capable d'intégrer de la
même façon qu'on fait avec une carte
graphique à l'intérieur j'utilisais
l'accélérateur de façon optimale pour
avoir des dons le moment il ya seulement
des puces qui on est et qui ont été
réalisés qui sont capables de faire
certaines tâches d'intégration système
qui va avec le soft reste acquis et tout
cela au niveau de choisir et encore pas
leur char sûr parce que la recherche sur
les meilleurs matériaux à utiliser ou
oui bien sûr ça aussi c'est clair que
ouais pourquoi pour les dispositions de
la logique que ce soit énormément aussi
de recherche au niveau des oui les
matériaux ses mots et tout et après les
plus grands défis sont encore
l'intégration comme se disait n'est pas
vraiment faisable d'avoir un
accélérateur qui non seulement est
inconstant alhaji qu'il faut intégrer
des composants digitaux ce qui veut dire
qu'il faut aller dans une fade ses mots
ce qui va être capable de faire il est
celui qui vont avec
donc voilà et c'est pas tous les
matériaux qui peuvent être absolument
donc
donc voilà ça tous les défis
d'intégration du tout qui sont vraiment
ces normes en fait c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui doit être retravaillé
donc se laisser bien y trouver des
nouveaux matériaux qui m'a capables de
j'aurai plus de précision et tout mais
après il faut être capable d'intégrer
ces matériaux non à l'intérieur de ses
noces avec les composants végétaux qui
il pas nécessairement mais qu'en pensent
les premières utilisations du
neuromorphic sont plus dans papy tout du
côté des datacenter auto des clients d
dur à dire mais ouais je dirais que
c'est surtout pour c'est sûr que
qu'elles sont au niveau des par exemple
d obliger ses skis plus attractif parce
que bon nécessairement besoin en fait
repris siemens qui compte le plus en
fait ce n'est qu'une caisse elle ajouté
et pour l'école les objets issus
habituellement on a quand même des puces
qui sont restés d'un certain nombre de
tâches spécifiques en fait qu'ils les
plus faciles pour deux énormes défis en
fait pour être capable de réaliser une
partie de ceux qui programment qui prive
un câble de femmes membres nomme un
nombre énorme de tâches
c'est plus facile évidemment de
construire une puce qui est restreinte à
un certain nombre de tâches spécifiques
qui serait simplement efficace en
énergie pour ces tâches la peau que pour
les data center par exemple ça prendrait
vraiment quelque chose qui peut
potentiellement elle tout ce qu'une
carte graphique peut pas rester dans une
énorme nombre de tâches et qui sont
toutes reliées au machine learning des
choses vraiment très programmables et
qui va être capable d'avoir des gains en
énergie qui sont beaucoup plus important
c'est le quart des effectifs suis
vraiment pas de données en fait
que je prends le membre et c'est surtout
les ça va être des déserts quelque chose
qui va plus régulier sur une face à la
fin est-ce que d'autres choses que notre
on n'a pas parlé je pense que c'est son
choix quand même
non je pense pas je pense que j'ai un
super bad cas merci beaucoup
très intéressant laquelle il accueille
daniel agger mais quand il prononce donc
et chercheurs donc à ibm zurich et qui
travaille notamment sur les questions
d'informatique quantique babou jours à
ce que tu pourras qu'on sépare
rapidement te présenter un peu tout cas
d'accord donc je m'appelle d'année à la
guerre j'en ai fait mon bac ch raymond
masse à lait psl et j'ai fait un bac
peuvent en allemagne sur le sujet du
contrôle quantique c'est à dire comment
contrôler sybille supraconducteurs
agents qui travaillent à un petit peu
dans le domaine de la finance
et depuis trois ans maintenant je suis
chez ibm en tant que chercheur et je
travaille la cure des applications et
calcul quantique est également sur
comment construire des ordinateurs
quantiques notamment sur la fin du
contrôle mécanique quantique pour
commencer pour ceux qui connaissent ray
avec naîtrait pas est ce que tu pourrais
présenter ce qu'est un ordinateur
quantique eu d'accord donc un ordinateur
quantique c'est une machine de calcul où
l'on traite l'information en écrivant
les règles de la mécanique quantique
donc quand on regarde un peu autour de
nous on voit que
la nature en quelque sorte elle tue les
lois de la mécanique classique mais
quand on regarde de plus près notamment
au niveau atomique
on se rend compte qu'il ya des
phénomènes un peu différent peut-être un
peu plus contre intuitif et ces
phénomènes prend justement réagi par les
lois de la mécanique quantique effet on
dit qu'ils ont fait de la mécanique
quantique qu'on cherche à traiter
l'information dans un ordinateur
quantique est donc comment fonctionne un
gonon un calcul quantique l'union
il ya plusieurs étapes dans un calcul
quantique
on y puise essentiellement 3 3 au retour
la superposition l'intrication et
l'interférence et je vais maintenant
détailler un peu chacune du cerveau sont
donc si on veut traiter l'information en
utilisant les lois de la mécanique
quantique
il nous faut stocker cette information
tant en systèmes quantiques et pour cela
on utilise en croire une [ __ ] qu'on
appelle donc en cubitt du coup et fait
un système qui a en effet de niveau 1 0
et 1
un peu comme les beats conventionnel les
beats classique et dont les cubistes une
des grandes différences c'est comme si
des systèmes quantiques
on peut le mettre dans une superposition
d'états
c'est à dire qu'on peut avoir à la fois
l'état zéro et en inde par exemple avoir
un état moins 50 % de probabilité de
mesurer sa route et cinquante pour cent
de probabilités de mesures est
maintenant figé thiboutot de qubits
j'aurai quatre états que je peux
potentiellement représenter à
l'intérieur de mon ordinateur en même
temps maintenant étant donné qu' on est
en train de traiter l'information en
utilisant les règles de la mécanique
quantique
on peut aussi utiliser l'intrication
c'est une ressource quantique en quelque
sorte qui nous permet d'introduire des
codes à l'action en les différents et
cantiques et c'est justement le genre de
nous qu'ils acceptent beatles dont
parlait einstein maintenant la dernière
est en quelque sorte
dans la grande majorité des calculs
quantiques pennetta d'interférences et
pour comprendre pourquoi on a besoin d'
interférer les différents états il faut
retourner un peu aux fondamentaux de la
physique quantique c'est à dire que
quand j'ai un système physique que je
prépare dans une superposition data et
que je me jure le système cette
superposition d'états que j'ai va enfin
retrouver à un seul état
avoir en quelque sorte qu'on appelle un
cola de la fonction d'onde ce qui veut
dire que quand on arrive à la fin d'un
calcul dans un ordinateur quantique il
faut interférer la probabilité des
différentes data pour que l'état qui a
la plus grande probabilité d'être
mesurée à celui qui correspond à la
pollution de notre problème peut-être un
truc à dire aussi c'est que lorsqu'on
fait une intrication de beaucoup de
qubits on a vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
d'étapes possible du coup d'état
quantique
donc en fait à chaque fois que je
rajoute à kiewit dans mon ordinateur
quantique jeu doublé le nombre de
départs que je peux représenter
simultanément donc avec deux cubes itx
et 4 est impossible 1 0 et 1 et manon et
je perds pas proa cubitt g8 data que je
peux représenter de manière simultanée
et donc à chaque fois que je rajoute
vaincu bits
je double le nombre n'est pas se dire
que lorsqu'on arrive à 50 public en fait
on a déjà énormément d'état possible
ici on a 1000 cubitt flins à plus de
détails de particules dans l'univers
exactement en fait il suffit d'avoir à
peu près 2 175 subite là pour pouvoir là
pour avoir une combinaison d'état qui
fois qui correspond à new york et fois
plus grand que le nombre d'atomes qui
existe dans l'univers regardable donc
c'est vraiment énorme
selon une eau et du coup quoi ça sert
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire avec un
ordinateur quantique
donc il ya certains calculs en fait que
l'on pourrait effectuer avec un
ordinateur quantique compte pas avec tes
avec un ordinateur classique comme par
exemple la factorisation on sait que la
factorisation fait un problème difficile
pour les ordinateurs classiques me fait
quelque chose qu'on pourrait effectuer
avec un ordinateur compte maintenant il
ya aussi beaucoup d'autres applications
d'un ordinateur quantique comme par
exemple simuler des systèmes physiques
en sait que la nature qui nous entoure
elle est au plus profond de soi même
quand il est donc
en fait de simuler la nature avec un
ordinateur quantique
des fois ça nous permettrait par exemple
de simuler les niveaux d'énergie dans
une bascule ou des réactions chimiques
ou mais pas seulement avec un ordinateur
quantique
on peut aussi s'attaquer à un problème
d'optimisation
ils sont difficiles pour les ordinateurs
classiques et on peut également faire
certaines tâches le fini la scion qui
pourrait être utilisé pour calculer on
va dire des métriques lloris donc soit
pas des applications dans le domaine
financier comme par exemple assez de
déterminer notamment des algorithmes ses
impressions c'est l'égoïsme de groover
il permet du coup de faire une
exploration d'une optimisation des coûts
plus rapide
kiko drastiquement plus rapide que
régulière hors du but les situe
exactement et donc par exemple dont les
applications pour le risque financier en
se balader tranquillement va sata le
rythme pour avoir par rapport aux
simulations schizo codra tig ou l'ordi
des c'est une actrice qui prend un
milliard de milliards des tables de
calcul ordinateur classique ça serait
vraiment beaucoup et pas faisable avec
un ordinateur quantique où on pourrait
faire ça en 1 milliards des tables
quelques semaines ce qui pourrait être
peut-être faisait oublier si
l'ordinateur quantique devine assez
puissant ils ont que passé le futur à ce
que on aura choqué un ordinateur
quantique chez soi ouais alors appris la
répondante à dire non tout simplement
parce que les ordinateurs quantiques qui
vont pas remplacer les ordinateurs
classiques conventionnel au contraire
ils vont servir à effectuer certaines
tâches que les ordinateurs classiques ne
peuvent pas ils vont être utilisés pour
accélérer certaines tâches maintenant
quand on regarde les applications
fatigué d'ordinateurs quantiques
c'est typiquement des problèmes que l'on
rencontre dans un milieu on va dire
professionnels ou industriels
donc déjà de produits là il n'y aura pas
un grand avantage à avoir un ordre
apple continue chez toi on va dire les
plus un autre aspect c'est que ce sont
des machines qui font entre elle veut
lumineux écouter on sait que les
systèmes quantiques sont très fragiles
en facilement perturbées par
l'environnement et c'est pour ça que par
exemple quand on considère la
technologie d ib un axe tort il faut
tout un système de refroidissement et
systèmes pour isoler en fait non bit
quantique de l'environnement et cela
rend en fait la chose très peu pratique
si on voudrait avant ça chez nous et en
fait c'est pour faire aux tic
aujourd'hui on peut accéder à les
ordinateurs quantiques à travers le
cloud peuvent encore faire des escales
ibm a mis à disposition du grand public
c'est assez pesant pas ce que fait clic
vous fait les calculs sur quelques
particules seulement c'est tout petit
mais il faut tout un système où tour
pour refroidir un peu regardants fait la
taille des équipes et on va avec les
quelques points qui m mais en fait tout
le film qui va autour du système de
refroidissement et bravo à large du
bouquet est ce que les ordinateurs
quantiques ces listes déjà ou est ce que
c'est
clown et science fiction ouais enfin
d'une certaine manière on pourrait dire
qu'elle a exigé la fin donc justement à
partir de 2010 a mis à disposition les
ordinateurs quantiques avec un cubi
initialement et puis maintenant on les
appelle et pour les partenaires du
réseau du bnq en avant des 53 kg et bêta
est ici il faut faire comprendre que le
fonds des systèmes qui font suffisamment
petit pour qu'un ordinateur classique
puisse les stimuler de manière efficace
et donc ses professeurs qui font euro
l'insee processeur conti ils ont tous en
quelque sorte un ordinateur quantique ça
qu'ils sont encore assez grand pour
pouvoir effectuer une tâche qu un
ordinateur classique le rapport actuel
il donc à n'importe qui peut accéder
utiliser les ordinateurs quantiques du
guide
exactement donc il suffit d'aller sur la
page web du deuxième contre-expertise
on peut faire encore et là on a accès
gratuitement à un professeur avec 5 et
qui vite et on l'a aussi accès à
différents tutorial et et en fait on a
aussi un réseau de partenaires
industriels et eux ils ont accès à des
professeurs qui ont leur équilibre qui
n'en avaient pas avoir enfin en train
cubitt aussi il faudra arriver à combien
de cubic pour que ce soit utile une
pratique qui ne put your way
alors ça c'est un peu difficile à dire
qu'on va peut-être nous prendre pour les
calicots contre est en quelque sorte
fait qu'elle est la performance d'un
ordinateur quantique et on adore ça en
utilisant le volume quantique donc le
volume quantique c'est une mesure qui
prend en compte le nombre de qubits mais
également d'autres aspects de
l'ordinateur quantique comme par exemple
la connectivité entre les différents
types plus on a de connectivité plus le
volume quantique en principe sera élevé
pour autant que les erreurs de nos
portes logiques et ils peuvent classer
encore un aspect qu'il faut prendre en
compte et à chaque fois qu'on manipule
l'information quantique qui est stocké
dans nos bits quantiques
on commet une petite erreur et il faut
que cet or pour la plus petite possible
et puis plus d'erreurs et petit plus le
volume quantique et grands maintenant si
on a un certain volume quantique c'est
encore par claire quel type de problème
on peut résoudre avec tel ou tel volume
quantique le lien entre les deux est
encore un sujet de recherche on va dire
quand par la connectivité c'est
l'intrication entre une particule amiens
alors fait effectivement comment les
cubis temps connecté entre heures si on
prend on va dire trop cuites
il pourrait être enfin chaque cube it
dans notre triomphe poète connecter à
notre quiz d'accord parce qu'on appelle
là
autour autres activités maintenant en
fait ces trois qui vident pourrait très
bien être représenté dans une ligne
c'est à dire que les cubitt extrémité
ils sont connectés au xive issus du
milieu mais pas à l'autre qui vide de
l'extrémité ce genre de collectivités en
fait il faut commencer à faire des
opérations supplémentaires pour pouvoir
par exemple un tri afrique et des cubes
et si on prend la chaîne de 3 cubitt et
que j'ai envie de faire une opération
entre les bus qui dit qu'ils font aux
extrémités de la chaîne
il faut d'abord que je la change un des
clips à l'extrémité avec la cuvée 2010
mais du coup ça on peut toujours faire
tous les calculs quantiques avec si on a
des cubis telle signé alors on pourrait
juste ce qu'il faut faire beaucoup
d'opérations d'échangé et du boulet
les algorithmes et efficace sur une
machine quantique voulait qu vite
souligné sue pas forcément les mêmes que
s'il quitte sous tous heureux alors en
fait on va faire fait qu'on va prendre
on va dire un algorithme puis on va
regarder les portes magiques qu'on a
fait entre les différents tubes it
et puis fit peut-être couple il ya deux
cubitt entre lesquels on va faire une
apparition ici on pas connecté on va
donc ensuite introduire de trois
opérations pour échanger des qubits pour
que en plus de faire l'algorithme est
donc le volume quantique aussi donc il
dépend beaucoup de fausses idées pas
fini tes explications sur une critique
jeter coupé schwazer a donc le volume
quantique qui libéreront de nombreuses
choses dépendent des heures des portes
magiques la connectivité entre l'équipe
et le nombre de québécois est aussi le
temps de cohérence des qubits donc le
temps de 40 pour expliquer le préfet est
plus ou moins la durée pendant laquelle
je peux te quai de l'information dans
mais qui dit par exemple je prépare un
état quantique
je vais seulement pour garder cette
information
on écrit bits
pendant le temps de cohérence au delà de
cette durée il y aura des perturbations
environnementales qui vont affecter
cette information qui fait que j'aime y
aurait donc aujourd'hui le temps de
cohérence ses sites non ça dépend un peu
des systèmes quantiques et pour pour les
cupides supraconducteurs par exemple on
est en train de regarder de l'ordre de
centaines de micro secondes on va dire
ok du coup on a le temps de faire tenir
d'opération ouais alors une porte la
gigue en fête chez les kids
supraconducteurs mur on va dire entre
une dizaine et qui quelquefois antenne
la nanoseconde
ok donc c'est ce fait mille une
opération que l'osm à peu près et ça ça
progresse comment donc justement il ya
beaucoup de recherches en fait qu'il est
en train de se faire pour améliorer
dépend de leur cohérence et un pour
faire ça il faut encore travailler pour
la fabrication des prototypes heures et
également sur la rive allemande à
l'environnement du coup si j'imagine
déjà parmi les défis mon ordinateur
constituent maintenant quand on regarde
un peu l'histoire du domaine les
premiers cubitt supraconducteurs quand
on a conclu il ya maintenant bien plus
de dix ans en arrière avec des plans de
cohérence du nano secondes
donc il faut se rendre compte qu'il y à
pas mal de progrès qui a été effectué
entre les premiers et quantique qui a
que quand la maman
cette annonce récemment de comme quoi
passer la supprime aussi quantique
depuis ce que tu expliquer ce qu'est la
supprime si ton ticket alors en fait à
l'ispm on se concentre pas vraiment sur
la suprématie complique nous on se
concentre plutôt sur le volume quantique
est notre objectif
a priori de doubler le volume quantique
chaque année
ok et la suprématie quantique tu peux
expliquer ce que c'est alors l'idée d'en
dans leur recherche c'est de démontrer
qu un ordinateur conflit qui est capable
de faire une tâche d'un ordinateur
classique ne peut pas égales nom qui
s'attachent utile et donc vous doubler
le volume quantique
tu as vous essayez de double oui quand
ils ont un instant vous êtes sur ce
rythme c'est ça pendant ce temps vous
vous êtes vous arrivée chaque année a
doublé
effectivement alors prêt dernières
années et justement donc pour pour
doubler la machine quantique et pendant
seulement augmenter le nombre de cubes
it mais également de diminuer les
erreurs mais partagée ok donc c'est
vraiment un travail de deux visions qui
sont à moitié d'ingénieurs en quelque
sorte le domaine de l'information
quantique c'est un domaine qui regroupe
beaucoup d' expertise dans des domaines
différents
donc il faut qu'à notre en physique il
faut sultanat fond programmatique mais
aussi en ingénierie par exemple il faut
beaucoup d'ingénierie électrique pour
comprendre un peu comme en ligne de
contrôle ont produit et donc je pense
que le progrès va vous arrivez vous à
l'écouté il volume donc nous tu vois le
futur des ordinateurs quantiques
ouais alors le but ultime en quelque
sorte dans des ordinateurs quantiques
évidemment nos achats d'ordinateurs
quantiques c'est de construire qu'on
appelle un ordinateur quantique
universel qui est onéreux erreur d'un
but après long terme et dans le court
terme justement on voit plutôt qu'on va
essayer d'aller vers cet objectif en
doublant le volume chronique et pour
cela donc il faudrait effectivement
augmenté le nombre de kribi et demi
d'une erreur des portes logiques
j'ai vu passer je connais pas très bien
de domaines mais j'ai vu passer quelques
quelques articles sur les algorithmes de
correction de code quantique c'est
prometteur ça sert à quoi
alors en fait l'idée c'est d'en traduire
une certaine redondance dans les calculs
au mécanisme mce de correction non
peut-être que la chose la première chose
qui nous viendrait à l'esprit est donc d
en biologique ont plusieurs villes
physique c'est à dire c'est à dire que
par exemple si je prends trois bits
quantiques physique je pourrais dire que
le 0 logique c'est l'état 000 et qu'il
n'est pas en logique pennetta en
maintenant si un seul des qubits qui vit
une erreur et que font des tâches ans
par exemple de 0,1
je peux ensuite regarder quelle est la
majorité de l'état des qubits dans ces
trois qui bits c'est à dire que si j'ai
un état zéro à zéro je vais considérer
ça comme en 0 logique et là j'ai déjà
introduit une certaine forme de
redondance dans le calcul un an les
codes de correction tels que les swaps
et codes vont justement utiliser des
principes similaires et encoder l'enfant
n'a pas encore dit que l'ebit plus
logique dont on a donc beaucoup de beats
et par an dont beaucoup de culot et est
ce que tu pourrais parler aussi un peu
plus de la petite musique où j'utilisais
à ibm qui sont nos petits coins son coût
des limites
ouais donc chez ibm en utilise qu'on
appelle des qubits supraconducteurs ce
sont en fait des petits circuits
électriques coeur ont plus profond et en
fait fait d'une capacité en parallèle
avec une injonction de joseph pham ngoc
sûrs de rien d'autre qu'une inducteurs
non linéaire
et en fait un système fait d'une
capacité d'une jonction de joss stone
forment un petit circuit électrique un
réseau non et la non linéarité des là
pour que l'on puisse adresser chaque
transition avec des pulls ou de contrôle
et on va former notre bits quantiques
avec les deux niveaux d'énergie les plus
bas de ce système
d'abord je suis en avoir tout compris
niveau d'énergie c'est le niveau
d'énergie
ces niveaux énergie de quoi exactement
cela peut correspondre à différents data
de charges ou de différentes attaques de
courant a d'abord un peu de
l'architecturé des cupides
supraconducteurs ils google com vous
fait une observation qu'une mesure du
système alors avec la technologique nous
on a en couple no no qubits avec des
résonateurs donc un résonateur ce n'est
rien d'autre qu'un câble coaxial
en appuyant coupés selon la tranche donc
c'est un petit système revenant qui a
une fréquence de résonance
et puis parce que ce système est couplé
avec le le qubit la fréquence de
résonance à dépendre de l'état du québec
et ça ça veut dire que pour faire une
mesure je peux envoyer un signal
électrique sur surtout résonateur et
analyser le signal qui est qui est
retourné le signal affectés et en
fonction de certaines propriétés de
signal je vais pouvoir donc déterminer
quel était l'état du bit parce que la
fréquence de résonance des résonateurs
répond nathalie que je vais peut-être un
peu vrai et il commet fait une porte
logique nous a semblé logique donc pour
faire une porte logique ce qu'il nous
faut faire c'est envoyer en plus de
contrôle sur le qui vive et typiquement
firme apprendront à dire une forte
logique et envers plata du clip on va
envoyer un signal qui correspond génial
électronique week-end vacances de
l'ordre
on va dire à peu près 4 à 7 giguère est
un signal contient suffisamment
d'énergie pour inverser l'état du public
donc en fait on a toute une technologie
de génération de signaux aux alentours
de lors des quelques guides verte pour
contrôler nos guides continue et cette
technologie en fait elle est plus ou
moins déjà disponibles parce que y en a
toute une industrie de l accord est
justement ce genre digne hockey et du
coup ça ressemble à quoi la rue alors
tout ton boulot tu as testé d'une
architecture du vote
qu'est ce que tu as fait exactement donc
par exemple dans certains cas certains
des projets que j'ai eu ce qu'on avait
intérêt à faire ça te regarder quels
genres de signaux est-ce qu'il faut
appliquer à différentes architectures
pour créer différents types de portes la
gic g du coup tu aimes bien souvent de
blues ce qui est des partis que tu me
ressembles à un travail qui en ferait
passer non je trouve qu'à simplement de
pouvoir isoler et contrôler un système
quantique est encore d'un est quelque
chose de très impressionnant et c'est
presque ça sinon en fait de pouvoir
faire rechercher par jour le jour est ce
que tu peux vous donc à 10 en début
d'interview qu'il y avait un problème
particulier qui est assez connue sur
lesquels les ordinateurs quantiques
seront meilleurs que les donateurs
classique s'ils ont beaucoup plus de
volume identique
quel point de la factorisation qu'il y à
des pointes de cryptographie classique
qu'est ce que tu veux un peu plus
d'écrire ce problème et au graphique
oui alors en fait on sait que certaines
formes de cryptographie asymétriques
sont vulnérables aux impacts des
ordinateurs quantiques maintenant là on
voit pas encore la cryptographie cas
maintenant l'application on va dire pour
les ordinateurs quantiques ans se
concentrent plutôt justement sur la
simulation de systèmes physiques et les
applications dans le domaine des
machines et de la finance maintenant
pour en revenir au thème de la
cryptographie
on n'a pas besoin d'un ordinateur
quantique pour ne pas être vulnérable
aux attaques des ordinateurs quantiques
on a en fait un processus
standardisation qui a lieu en ce moment
qui est mené par là et en fait on peut
utiliser certains rythmes classiques qui
feront donc leurs augustes aux
ordinateurs quantiques
tout un poème j'entendis parler du une
compétition en fait sur plusieurs
algorithmes de cryptographie classique
vous nous faire une compétition possible
voir quel est le meilleur
exactement on a aussi fille à aulas
boali bn les gens qui travaillent dans
ce genre de problème mais quand tu as
parle aussi de machine learning antique
du coup d'accord donc l'application que
j'ai en fait c'est la classification et
plus spécifiquement en regardant fait la
machine la ligne classique en après
l'appel à ce project la chine c'est un
outil qui nous permet de classifier des
années comme par exemple on va dire à
des clients qui auraient acheté un
serpent produits les clients qui
n'auraient pas acheté ce produit est en
effet de classifier en fonction
peut-être de certaines de leurs
caractéristiques
les clients des deux groupes maintenant
des fois les données ne sont pas
séparables comme par exemple si on
regarde des pointures une ligne si les
points aux mille
une certaine catégorie et il fait aux
extrémités cependant une autre catégorie
c'est pas facile de tracer une ligne ici
un pour séparer deux catégories donc du
coup ce qu'on peut faire mais ça c'est
toujours un dans le milieu classique on
peut introduire les nouvelles
caractéristiques comme par exemple
prendre le car et de la position du
point sur la ligne puis ça après ça nos
défis d'une parabole et en utilisant
cette parabole
on peut ensuite séparé les points milieu
mais points qui sont aux extrémités
maintenant si on a un ordinateur
quantique à notre disposition on peut
utiliser qu'on appelle en coin que fitch
maths c'est à dire qu'on va produire des
nouvelles caractéristiques
en utilisant un processus quantique est
typiquement ces processus
ils ne font pas calculable de manière
efficace sur un ordinateur classique et
puis donc ça va nous permettre peut-être
de détecter certaines corrélations dont
les données auxquelles on n'a pas accès
autrement et il faut comprendre que dans
cette application
le bénéfice se ferait par exemple de
réduire les erreurs des classifications
qu'ont effectuée par contre on n'a
aucune garantie qu'on va justement
atteindre cet objectif il faut enfin sa
fille et qui voit des femmes à réussir
et du coup de trique antique
c'est un lieu à la fois à
l'apprentissage est une fiction ou juste
à l'autre en tissage
donc en fait on va faire tous là tout le
processus en quelque sorte dans la dans
l'ordinateur quantique on va faire
l'apprentissage en utilisant un circuit
quantique et en fit scandale et circuits
quantique pour clarifier et donner ni
qu'est-ce qu'il y aura des phases ou
parce que du coup il faut quand même un
ordinateur quantique pour faire des
prédictions actuellement est ce qu'il ya
des chevaux des ventes recherches pour
essayer de voir un apprentissage contre
déploiement ainsi qu une bonne 14e nuit
pas au courant
notre agrément s'est donc jeté ses dents
formule 1 parce que tout ce que tu as
des as une idée c'est que parfois
lorsqu'on a des données coupé en deux
quoi souvent on essaye on s'appelle
lignières dans deux villes parfois on
peut pas avoir de bonne séparation
l'ignorent et du coup l'idée c'est de
rajouter des dimensions et de calculs de
dimension du coût de l'ordinateur
quantique serait capable de bien trouver
efficacement
c'est une nouvelle dimension alors
quelqu'un d'un ordinateur classique
qu'il faudrait beaucoup plus de calculs
en fait l'ordinateur conflit qui nous
permet d'introduire des caractéristiques
que qui sont difficiles à calculer avec
un ordinateur conventionnel mais est ce
que tu penses que ça serait possible que
toute cette voiture moteur quantique
finalement le progrès n'arrive pas à
continuer est ce que c'est possible
s'est soumis une ddn ou est ce que tu es
très confiant sur le futur moi je suis
assez confiant sur la future compte en
regardant peut-être le progrès qu'il a
effectués ces dix dernières années on va
dire et quand même 35 ans par exemple en
2007 on avait les preuves à faire
compliquer avec un cube it disponible
via le cloud et maintenant on va
justement introduire des processeurs
avec en trois cabines est d'autant plus
qu'il faut utiliser rendre compte que
certaines de la recherche qu'on fait
pour les ordinateurs quantiques peuvent
aussi être utilisé dans d'autres
domaines
et ça c'est donc un acte et maintenant
on est si tout un aspect comment dire de
formation aussi non ibm a organisé
plusieurs camps pour apprendre à et
jeunes chercheurs
les programmeurs comme on programmera un
ordinateur quantique est justement en
fait un piéton qui est un langage de
programmation qui est aujourd'hui très
utiles à connaître mais c'est aussi
quelque chose qui va nous permettre en
quelque sorte de découvrir les
applications du futur est finalement un
des aspects que je trouve les plus
excitants fait que en effectuant cette
recherche sur les ordinateurs quantiques
on découvre aussi des choses sur le
monde qui nous entoure
à
et on peut donc justement on a pris
connaissance du monde qui nous entoure
ça fait quelque chose de trouver très
excitant ce qu'était d'autres exemples
de domaines liés à la supraconductivité
s'il ya plein d'autres par exemple aussi
ça nous permet de pousser notre
compréhension des processus chimiques
qui ont lieu justement dans ce système
avec les canons qu'on soit allé les
cupides supraconducteurs puisque pendant
la supraconductivité ya beaucoup de
recherches sur des outils la
supraconductivité à température ambiante
ce que ça s'enlève actionnerait
ordinateur quantique ou est-ce que ce
qui aurait des lions alors en fait la
raison pour laquelle on a besoin d'un
système de refroidissement dans nos
systèmes quantiques
c'est parce que la transition en énergie
de transition entre le zéro et le 1 est
de l'ordre de 5 à 7 giguère manouan fait
pour que convertir cette énergie en une
température et puis sa température est
de l'ordre de 240 milliken vite à peu
près qui veut dire que si on veut
protéger la probable quantique est
fluctuante et environnemental il faut
avoir un film de refroidissement qui est
qui attend des températures beaucoup
plus profonde que les 240 médical ville
parce que s'il ya trop de niveaux
d'énergie
vu que tu as et aux alentours en fade et
si on a paré de programmes font de la
programmation quantique sur python du
coup vous avez une librairie pour écrire
des codes antique donc ibm a mis à
disposition du public général et on est
en train de concevoir une librairie qui
s'appelle qu'il quitte le même famille
sont partout inquiète était en fait tous
les obstacles qui nous permet de
contrôler les ordinateurs quantiques
c'est à dire que au niveau des plus
élevés on a les applications comme par
exemple simuler des molécules et puis au
niveau le plus profond on a justement la
génération des pubs de contrôle
qui nous permet de contrôler un
ordinateur quantique et voit du coup je
me disais plein plein plein d'étapes
intermédiaires afin d'écouter trait aux
jeux hardware d'un truc un peuple est-ce
que c'est difficile d'apprendre un
programme mêlant quantique c'est quand
même a pas de calcul qui est très
différent donc il faut connaître un peu
d'alzheimer de physique et il faut aussi
réussir à comprendre que sa carte
circuit quantique c'est à dire quel est
l'effet de faire telle porte le gigaset
maman comme la suite super puisque tu as
quelque chose d'autre à rajouter je
crois que pour l'instant on a touché
plus de moments à à bout de la chaîne
les ordinateurs quantiques superbe à
merci beaucoup en tout cas pour beaucoup
dans merci merci beaucoup
bonne continuation l'afnor merci quelque
chose vous pouvez m'écrire ce genre et
si vous avez des photos ou des vidéos
que des chocs frontaux uniquement en
audio mais bon merci ok merci beaucoup
merci que vous voyez du coup vous voyez
le registre mondiaux tout à fait un
super haut